2 1 c'est parti merci madame québec
les premiers tours comme ça c'est
psychologique
il attaque à main jaune en plus
généralement doivent une étape et
dernière étape où c'est un peu des vies
a sévi on a pas que jamais jonas
énormément d'heures non ce que pour
autant dire que la lutte et amie rapide
voyez donc comme il est debout savant
dans le morceau de l'agent de la montée
dans la journée commence à redescendre
de maîtriser le vent
vient suivre la défend toujours opter 59
ans j'ai dû me donne à fond de la moitié
l'ordre
l'atténuation maillot jaune bon ce n'est
là
bon
le plus beau souvenir je dirais que
réunionnais qui gagnent donc c'est le
principal je pense pas nous et en plus
un coureur qui le méritent surtout la
beauté du paysage pour nous c'est la
première fois qu'on y est on a découvert
un peu avec un julien loubet qui nous a
vraiment fait montrer ce qu'ils valent
et et c'était quoi le niveau d'un
professionnel ait maintenant les six
mois et ont commencé les prochaines et
les meilleurs c'est beau souvenir
me demande mon bien je vous remercie
vraiment là c'est une belle image pour
vélos nous que tout ce monde